at this altitude I can run flat-out for
my this episode is brought to you by
four Sigma deck
you might remember forward sig Matic for
their mushroom coffee which was created
by those clever Finnish founders and
when I first mentioned that coffee on
this podcast the products sold out in
less than a week it lights you up like a
Christmas tree which can be really
useful however recently I've been
testing the opposite side of the
spectrum a new product and that is their
reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my
day to get to sleep as you guys may know
longtime listeners at least I struggled
with insomnia for decades I have a
largely fixed that but still shutting
off my monkey brain has never been easy
still isn't easy very often and I found
reishi which have been fascinated by for
a few years now has been very very
effective in calming their old formula
however for sig Maddox old formula
included stevia and I like to avoid
sweeteners all sweeteners for a host of
reasons and I then just ping them and
asked hey guys
I would love to experiment with this and
maybe actually suggest it but I'd like a
version without sweeteners if you'd be
open to it if too much of a headache
don't worry and they are always game for
experimentation so they created a
special custom version without the
stevia without sweeteners now it is part
of my nightly routine their ratio elixir
comes in single serving packets which
are perfect for travel and in fact I'm
about to leave the country right now and
I have a packet in front of me that's
just gonna sit in the end of my carry-on
bag you only need hot water and it mixes
very very easily here's some recommended
copy that they put in the read so I'm
gonna read it and I'll give you my take
quote a warning for those in the
experimental mindset reishi is strong
and bitter in parentheses like any great
medicine so if the bitterness is too
much I recommend trying it with honey
or nut milk such as almond milk and
quote so I'm gonna say no you should
suck it up and you should drink the tea
because it's not that bitter and maybe
you should take the advice of all
Chinese people when they're criticizing
young uns when they say boo and I'm sure
cool which means you're not able to eat
bitterness bitter is in many cases an
indication of things that help liver
detoxification and so on not saying
that's the case here but I've tested
this ratio later on family members on
friends everybody has liked it it's a
little bit earthy it's not that hard so
I would just say suck it up and know
don't put it in honey or nut milk or any
of that just drink the goddamn tea
it's delicious I think right if you like
poo air that kind of stuff that type of
tea you're gonna dig it so just try it
okay back to then my read if you'd like
to naturally improve your sleep both on
set and quality I think naturally you
might just enjoy this ratio lecture
without any sweeteners it has organic
reishi extract organic fueled mint
extract organic rosehips extract organic
Tulsi extract and that's it no fancy
stuff no artificial whatchamacallit
anything so check it out go to four
sigma tech comm forward slash ferrous
and get 20% off this special batch I
don't know if they're gonna be making
much more of this since it was made
specifically for you guys so do me a
favor and try it out so that they
continue to be open to experimenting
with me to create products for you guys
specifically check it out for Sikkim
addict that's fo you are SI GMA TI c
calm /e ferrous f e RR ISS and get 20%
off the special batch and you must use
the code ferrous to receive your
discount fer our ISS so again go to four
Sigma 2 comm forward slash ferrous and
then use code ferrous for 20% off of
this rare exclusive limited run of
reishi mushroom elixir for nighttime
routines without any sweeteners enjoy
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books man oh man do a lot of listeners
of this podcast and readers of mine love
fresh books to the extent that I ended
up meeting with the CEO not very long
ago why are they so popular well they
are the number one cloud accounting
software designed exclusively for
self-employed professionals that's many
of you and used by more than 10 million
people you can send invoices track your
time and get paid very very quickly
which suits the needs of a lot of
freelancers a lot of entrepreneurs and
beyond you can take pictures of receipts
you can link your credit card and debit
cards so all the things you buy
automatically appear in your fresh books
in the right category so on and so forth
makes taxes easy makes invoices easy
makes your life easier and also in fact
I would recommend a PDF they didn't ask
me to read this part by the way they put
the other PDF a while back called
breaking the time barrier subtitle how
to unlock your true earning potential so
you can search for breaking the time
barrier a lot of people ask me how can I
get a 4-hour workweek with a service
business and the story in that ebook its
PDF is the short answer it's really
really good so I think you should also
check that out so breaking the time
error check it out but also why not test
out fresh books claim your 30-day
unrestricted free trial at fresh
ebooks.com forward slash tim and enter
tim ferriss two hours in two S's in the
how did you hear about us section that
sounds like we're gonna get very little
tracking that's a lot of work but just
go to fresh books calm forward-slash tim
and try it out because it is a very good
product and i think you will find it
simplifies your life
enjoy
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where typically it is
my job to deconstruct world-class
performers of all different types from
different fields to tease out the habits
routines etc that you can apply in your
own life this time around I am going to
answer questions myself I have had some
modicum of success with the podcasting
and blog worlds remember those web logs
blogs and recently received a number of
questions via text and email which I
requested from muddy Takahashi who is
Mari Takashi
atomic Mari you can find her on
Instagram at atomic Mari ma RI
eat some also on the authority of us and
she has had a lot of success on
platforms that I am less familiar with
like YouTube for instance video all
sorts of different things she's a very
accomplished ballerina gamer and content
creator in her own right so I thought
that I might answer her questions as a
podcast episode because these are
informed questions and they are
questions that I sometimes get from
other people so the podcast this podcast
that you're listening to has almost 300
million downloads now and is the first
business interview podcast to cross a
hundred million downloads so we have
that in terms of data and lots of
mistakes and trial by fire and then the
blog that is tim dot blog receives
between three and four million unique
visitors per month so there's certainly
bigger podcast there's certainly bigger
blogs but doing pretty well in some top
percentile I would say and operating
with a very very lean team so I have one
maybe two depending on how you define it
full-time employees and a handful of
part-time assistants for various things
and it is in comparison with many of
these shows you would recognize
otherwise and say the iTunes top 50 a
skeleton Krew many of these shows have
20 30 different staffers working on
shows in various capacities this is
particularly true with more complex
productions like some of those from NPR
for instance and you can just listen to
the credits at the end to get an idea so
I have kept this format very very simple
with this podcast to facilitate working
with a lean team all right so let's jump
into it so muddy again you can find her
on instagram at atomic Mari asks a
number of different things and I'm gonna
modify some of the questions here just a
broad in the application and if you hear
me unzipping my jacket that's because
I'm getting really haven't excited about
this number one what equipment do you
use when you're on the road does it
differ from what you use at home it does
not differ at this point in time I
travel with a number of pieces of
equipment and generally speaking we're
talking about the zoom 0o m h6 which i
use is a recorder it could fit in a
large pocket it is not a gigantic device
and this allows me to connect as many as
or more than four XLR cables so very
basic I think I typically get three to
six foot XLR cables which then connect
to the mic that I am using right now and
this is the shore KS m8 microphone which
is fantastic for voice recording even in
loud environments I have used and still
have the shure sm58 switch were
introduced to me by bryan callen
stand-up comedian and podcaster
extraordinaire in his own right the
fighter and the kid along with Brendan
Schaub and this is a very simple setup
it's very hard to break and I would
encourage that you also use this is a
new addition took me a while to find the
proper tool for this but rechargeable
batteries and a loop Panasonic and a
loop en e l oo P for a double-a or
triple-a in the case of the h6 it's
Double A and I would encourage that you
buy the charger which charges in three
hours and it can sustain up to 70% of
its charge for
up to ten years so this this is after
some vetting the best what I would say
rechargeable batteries that you can use
otherwise a piece of advice is to always
use new batteries because you will find
this is advice I received from a very
experienced interviewer if you try to
squeak out the last bit of a battery you
will find very often that you stick it
into a recorder like this and it shows
that it's three-quarters full
and then ten minutes into the interview
potentially with someone you really do
not want to piss off with having to do
an equipment change it drops down to the
very last bar and then you find yourself
in a bad position so new batteries every
time and these rechargeables I find very
very helpful so that is the basic setup
there are a few other options and few
things that I travel with when in and
out if I'm not bringing this even if I
don't think I'm going to have to record
anything I will bring the ATR 2100 which
is an audio technica mic that is USB
connected to a laptop for instance and I
can use then a quick time to record
anything I might need that is the ATR
2100 audio technica mic which provides
an incredible bang for the buck and you
could use that and I use that for all of
my remote interviews weather over Skype
or some other platform Zen caster and so
on there many different options you can
look into I tend to just use Skype and
ECAM call recorder ECAM call recorder is
the software and it's very simple there
are downsides but nonetheless it is the
software I'm most consistently used
there are others like I mentioned Zen
caster that record a copy locally and
then automatically upload to a service
like Dropbox so that you have high
quality audio from both sides that you
can then access as the interviewer okay
another piece of equipment that I used
for many years and it served me very
very well but then recently gave up the
ghost is the I XM yellow tech and this
is an all-in-one device from Germany
that is
self-contained in the sense that you
have the batteries the SD cards
everything in the mic itself and you can
record playback insert a headset and so
on all from this one mic and that you
can put it in this case stick into a
backpack it's about the size of a tiny
tiny fold up umbrella in effect and that
served me very very well I use that to
record I would say 60 to 70 intros I
used it for intro specifically because I
always record my intros after the
interviews all right let's move on those
are the basics in terms of equipment and
I am experimenting with a number of mics
from sure and other manufacturers for
using the Lightning port on say an
iPhone to record from a directional mic
I have not yet made much progress in
those tests and I really like my setup
with the h6 it's extremely extremely
reliable number two I'm going to move
the order around a little bit any
pointers on being a good interviewer
alright I get this question a lot and I
would suggest this is a great question
but I would suggest that we start with a
different question and that is pregame
how do you set yourself up for a
successful interview which is different
from being a good interviewer few
suggestions number one is that you chat
via video even if you're not going to
record video I typically don't say via
Skype and ask a number of questions make
a number of points and ask a number of
questions so I always emphasize first
you have Final Cut so if there's
anything I'm talking to the interviewee
if there's anything that you want to cut
out afterwards just let me know this is
not live we can cut anything out that
you want to cut out and what that means
is I encourage you to be as detailed as
raw as yourself as possible cursings
fine I curse I'm from Long Island and we
can always cut things out we can't put
interesting things back in so please be
yourself number two if you need to take
a break go to the bathroom grab some
water just let me know how to pause in
the action and we can stop it
and number three the that the general
structure is the following and I might
say it will bounce around it's not going
to be chronological I will probably
start with a question about X I like to
tell people the first question that I'm
going to start with and that's something
that I very often ask say TV
interviewers or others when I'm being
interviewed I don't need to know all the
questions just tell me what the first
question is so that I don't stumble
right out of the gate so I tell them
you're probably gonna start with this
question first third is going to bounce
all over your bio we're going to talk
about your life you will have a chance
and I will bring it up certainly towards
the end to talk about your book your
movie whatever it is that they want to
promote or talk about and I generally
say we want the audience to fall in love
with you first the messenger and then
the message and selling whatever it is
that you would like to encourage them or
persuade them to buy do etc is much
easier so we're gonna bounce around
first say first third assuming it's a 90
minute interview and we're just kind of
how I set the expectation typically and
then the second third will be very often
some of my rapid-fire questions or
questions from the audience then we will
talk about your book
movie whatever it might be and then
close up with some additional rabbit for
our questions and at the very end I will
ask you do you have a final ask or
recommendation next step suggestion
whatever it might be for my audience any
parting thoughts all right so I set the
stage you notice that I'm really laying
out a map of the territory for them and
enabling them to the greatest extent
possible to be comfortable this is
before I hit record or ask the first
question there are a few other things I
like to ask number one is there anything
you would like to avoid talking about
anything that you're tired talking about
anything like that and we can certainly
cut it out later but I can also make an
attempt to avoid it if if you would like
and I'm not going to get into politics
I'm not going to touch on any suppose
it's candles or whatever this isn't a
gotcha show this is show about tactics
and routines favorite books things that
my readers can use things that will
inspire and help my readers get through
their own challenges
from their own mistakes etc this is not
a gotcha show and I put people at ease
with that as well and then last went out
very often asked is do you have any
greatest hits stories and I will I will
very frequently pose this question
before we have our chat so I'll send
something like this via email but are
there any cues that I could use such as
you know tell me about that time in
fourth grade when you know your teacher
threw your chair across the room or
whatever it might be oh there any cues I
can use to bring up stories that you
have seen audiences respond extremely
well to that are really powerful really
funny whatever it might be and folks who
are interviewed or people who talk for a
living or do a fair amount of talking
will over time just like stand-up
comedians work on their material and the
the smarter of them or the smart of them
will keep track of this of course that
and naturally do this so they will know
that they have three or four absolute
guaranteed hits for almost any audience
so I'll ask them if they have any of
those than any cues that I could use to
bring them up and even if they're having
trouble with that formulation I'll say
any particularly funny stories that
people enjoy hearing and I will then
have two or three of those that I will
front load somewhere in the first third
of the interview right first 30 minutes
and this guarantees a that the
interviewee gets to work on or rather
repeat a story that they're very
comfortable telling that they know will
work which tends to put them in a good
mood and also it acts as a confidence
builder and B I know that I will have at
least one to three hooks so that I grab
the listeners in the first 30 minutes
and very often in the first five to ten
okay this is all before I ask the first
question and then when we ask questions
I'll have no more than
say a two-page spread in a notebook open
with three to five points on either side
so for a 90 minute to three hour
interview I'll have no more than ten
points and very frequently I will follow
then the thread of conversation with
follow-up questions and will only hit
half of those maybe all right do not
come into an interview expecting to ask
2025 questions it's just not gonna
happen
if you are actually listening to the
answers and not rushing through things
which leads me to a few other
suggestions number one ask questions
that you actually care about ask
questions you want to know the answer to
all right and some now some interviewers
for instance James Lipton Inside the
Actors Studio he knows the answers to
every question he is going to ask and he
very rarely deviates from the order of
the questions on these blue cards they
also this is where I got it from allow
their guests to have final cut they
record for about three hours I want to
say and then cut it down to whatever it
is in its finished form 45 to 60 minutes
I would rather have a slightly more
awkward conversation but not know the
answers otherwise it's boring for me so
I may know the answers to a handful of
questions but very rarely and I tend to
spend as little time as possible on
something you could read in Wikipedia
unless I'm digging into a particular
aspect that wasn't covered or that might
be fun to explore I also tend to start
with questions that they don't expect
about perhaps a side interest you'll
notice that for instance in my interview
with Edward Norton we started with
surfing why because Edwards a very smart
guy he spent a lot of time with media if
I start with asking about a specific
role for instance that or the beginning
of his acting career he will go he might
not saying Edward would do this but he
might go on autopilot I would and a lot
of people do when they're asked about
the topics that they've covered a
thousand times before they have an
automatic response very often so I'll
start was surfing which is what I did in
that case or start with say in the case
of Terry Crews the interview with Terry
Crews one of my favorites in the last
six months and certainly one of the most
popular huge huge episode that continues
to get downloaded hundreds of thousands
of times per month it began with talking
about his artwork something people are
are not very aware of and something that
really blew me away because he's an
extremely extremely gifted and developed
graphic artist all right so there you
have it to avoid people going on
autopilot and ask questions you care
about next let the silence do the work
this is advice that I received from Hal
fuss men interviewer extraordinaire has
interviewed everyone from say Gorbachev
to Clooney - I mean Muhammad Ali good on
the list he has interviewed just about
all of the cultural shapers of the last
50 years I mean it's it's an incredible
list and Cal is a true Jedi of the craft
and when I meet someone and develop a
friendship with someone like that this
includes for instance at one point I
hired a researcher who had worked on
inside the Actor's Studio
I will ask them very nicely and
something along the following lines I
know you're probably too busy but if
there's any chance I could send you a
transcript of one or more of my episodes
I would really appreciate any thoughts
or comments or feedback that you might
have because I know I am probably
missing the boat or wasting
opportunities that come up or rushing or
doing something that a novice is prone
to doing and I really want to make the
most of these opportunities when I'm
speaking with these incredible people it
would really mean a lot to me even if it
were just a few lines of feedback but I
totally understand if you're too busy to
reply and Cal very kindly at one point
read through a few of my transcripts and
his his most important feedback was
let the silence do the work and this
takes some practice because in normal
conversation which is not the same as an
interview and people have different
approaches certainly I mean Joe Rogan is
spectacular he has a very conversational
style James Lipton has a very very
strict I would say interview style I'm
somewhere in the middle and that suits
my personality in this context let the
silence do the work means if you ask a
question and there is silence awkward
silence for a few seconds a few seconds
is a really long time in conversation we
try to just sit still for say five
seconds alright let's let's actually
pretend that I'm asking you a question
so what was it like when that happened
that's about five seconds it's a
long time and my instinct which is true
for millions and billions of people was
to jump in and try to help the
interviewee and I'd say well put another
way or we could come back to that and
ask another question and how's advice
was let the silence do the work just
wait it out and this is easier via Skype
than it is in person in my experience
but let the silence do the work and
those are a few pointers to start with
there are many more study treated as a
craft to treat it as a class I collect
questions that other people ask I
collect questions that I see in
in-flight magazines and interviews I
test these and if they don't work I take
them out so for instance early on I
would ask not only the question when you
hear the word success who's the first
person you think of which Derek Siver's
and other guests rightly pointed out on
the first go-around seldom produces a
very interesting answer often it's
either my parents or Elon Musk or Steve
Jobs these are those these are the three
most common answers so I would have to
say I started then saying aside from
your parents Steve Jobs or Elon Musk and
I stopped asking that question because
it is it rarely produces the story or
insights that I want my readers to be
able to apply
I also used to ask the question when you
think of the word punchable whose face
comes to mind this is a really
problematic bad question because it puts
people on the defense they don't want to
say things they might regret it's not a
good question
but I borrowed it from someone else
because it seemed very clever now I did
once get an amazing story that kind of
made it worth it up to that point
fumbling with this question with Tony
Robbins in the first interview also one
of the biggest episodes I've ever
published so if you want to check that
out he Tim dot blog forward slash Tony
probably goes to the right place and he
talked about a meeting with Obama which
is hilarious so that's that's certainly
worth listening to and one of those
times when I wondered oh god I hope my
audio equipment is working it's very
funny all right moving on because I know
we could go really really deep on that
and I would say that if you want to
understand how I craft questions how I
test questions what makes a good
question in my opinion then I suggest
going to tribe of mentors calm the
introduction is there for free and in
the introductory chapter they had to use
this book chapter I talked about
crafting questions so you can check that
out or you just buy the book it's
whatever it is 10 bucks or something ok
next question how far ahead do you get
with banking content or episodes this
depends on when you catch me very often
I will Bank I would say several weeks in
advance minimum I tend to record and
this comes back to the batching concept
in the 4-hour workweek I I tend to
record and have phone calls
this would include interviews on Mondays
and Fridays so Mondays and Fridays are
my audio days whether that's just
walking outside and making ten phone
calls or recording podcast episodes so I
schedule people on Mondays and Fridays
so that my my week isn't interrupted
with scattered recording periods
that's point number one aside from that
I also schedule content creation weeks
once a quarter where one of my teammates
will fly out we won't meet here in
Austin and we will record a week a
week's worth of audio video etc for
various purposes we will also make
editorial decisions for the coming
quarter and then front-load not only in
terms of recording audio for podcast but
also video for social and make editorial
decisions about guest contributors and
so on for the upcoming three months and
that that really covers a lot of ground
for us so I'd say in a general I like to
have at least four episodes in the bank
pre-recorded because I'm publishing on
average six episodes a month and I
decided on that frequency because I
found two episodes per week so eight per
month to overwhelm me when listening to
long-form audio and I found six to be
just enough to support the on the number
of interviews that I want to do which
are all very personal I'm reaching out
to all of these interviewees to solve
very personal problems or improve
aspects of myself
they're always personally driven and
that's that's roughly the cadence that I
want to sustain so six per month that
means you have two weeks per month with
the single episodes and two weeks per
month with two episodes
decided on that I like to have at least
four ready to rock and roll in case I
get sick in case I lose my voice I get a
sinus infection whatever it might be and
very often I'll have more than that
sometimes I get caught on my heels and
then I have to do something last-minute
but that is also my nature and that's
something I recommend emulating okay
next question is how do you recommend
seeking out a podcast network what are
the advantages disadvantages this is
really question of how much of an
entrepreneur or business owner manager
you want to be there are many friends I
have recommended
seek out or contact different podcast
networks and these podcast networks
offer various services that range from
production assistance post-production
editing guest recruitment in some cases
to advertising sales the focus tends to
be on advertising sales because that is
how they are incentivized to make money
sorry for the sniffling that is cedar
fever
the advantages are you are offloading a
tremendous amount of labor assuming that
they do their job and do it well and on
time the disadvantage is that you tend
to make a lot less money and that is a
fair trade
there are also some issues if you and
will come back to this if you are
positioning your podcast as I position
mine as very high-end and premium I will
be charging a CPM rate that's cost per
thousand mil right cost per a thousand
downloads that is very very high and by
high I mean sixty to a hundred dollars
CPM that is extraordinarily high and you
have to make it worth it and based on
renewal rates for sponsors that is
certainly the case for this podcast
however most podcasts is including many
NPR shows are billing out at say $12 CPM
$15 CPM so 25% or less of what I am
charging and you can run into an issue
if you are trying to create a premium
product with say a very highly educated
audience with at high average household
income which this audience certainly is
that the podcast networks are
unaccustomed to selling premium products
they are more accustomed to selling 10
to $20 CPM and you will get pushback if
you try to position in a premium fashion
and they will or they might agree to it
then after the fact say we can't sell at
$60 $70 $80 CPM we can only sell at
12 and then all of your financial
predictions go out the window because
you are estimating your percentage gross
or net based on an assumption a premium
and then the feedback is we can't sell
at premium so those are some of the
disadvantages or risks but I have many
friends who are fantastic interviewers
they are not organized enough in a
entrepreneurial or finance capacity to
actually train up internal staff for ad
sales if they decide to do that for
instance and might as well touch on this
point which is ads okay ads are not
something monetizing is not something
I'd recommend you focus on off the bat
and if the reason you're doing a podcast
is for that I don't think you're gonna
last very long generally speaking you
really have to have an itch that you are
scratching something you need to get out
into the world because it is less
painful more enjoyable but often less
painful for you to get it out into the
world than to keep it in your own head
okay if this is certainly true with
ebooks as well and I write a lot more
about this in an article that I have on
the blog Tim Dodd and you can just
search how I built a number one-ranked
podcast with 60 million downloads the
funny part about that of course is that
60 million at the time was huge to me
now it's closer to 300 million but the
principles still apply and I talk a lot
about if and when to monetize generally
speaking I would recommend that you
monetize only after you have at least a
hundred thousand downloads on average
per episode because this gives you the
leverage and the reach to interact with
sponsors who can grow with you who have
the company size and the marketing
budget to increase the price per episode
or their ability to pay an increased
price per episode even if you double in
size if you try to monetize really early
you're gonna be doing in many cases
sketchy affiliate deals or good to feel
it affiliate deals with moderate payout
and you'll then if if you're dealing
with people who are paying
you per episode and I would suggest no
terms I don't use any term so everyone's
paying upfront there's another thing you
only get a few established a reputation
most of the time they're gonna ask for a
net 13 at 60 which can create cash flow
problems for all of those reasons and
more develop a solid product a solid
audience before you attempt to monetize
you know would you rather make a
thousand dollars a month now or $500,000
a month later and the the difference
between those two is often one of
delaying the compulsion to monetize for
when you actually have leverage okay now
let's build on that because I get so
many damn questions about monetizing
that like to encourage a few different
approaches the renewal rate of sponsors
for my show despite the pricing which is
very high is I want to say at least 70
to 80 percent it may be more so why is
my renewal rate so high and why is that
important it's important because a I'm
lazy and I don't want to have a high
churn rate that necessitates pitching
new sponsors and converting new sponsors
endlessly that is very high labor and
not something I have any desire for
second I'm unhappy sponsors happy
sponsors happy podcaster assuming
they're not high maintenance in other
ways so I do fire sponsors if they're
high maintenance but the the key here is
that I vet the sponsors very carefully
and personally use them so there have
been delays of two to four months for
sponsors who want to in this case right
you know $250,000 $500,000 checks to pre
book episodes actually an important
nuance so I don't offer any discounts on
episodes if they buy more episodes
because the popularity of the podcast as
it ramps up increases the price that
they pay per episode so the way that a
sponsor gets a discount is by booking in
advance because if they booked say six
episodes for
- and we're in q1 the podcast is gonna
continue to grow and they've locked in a
current price when the price is
inevitably gonna go up because the
popularity continues to grow just as a
side note again one of many policies
that keeps my life and maybe your life
very very simple okay there are two
different ways that I vet sponsors
number one I personally use the products
when possible in some cases say b2b
products that's a little more
challenging but for that reason you'll
see a strong preference for four
consumer products of different types
services that I use myself and I also
pull my audience late at night on social
media and will ask has anyone out there
used fill in the blank from zero to ten
how much would you recommend it to a
friend
ten being the best and I do this late at
night because I don't want the companies
to notice this and then spam the
out of the feed with their employees
friends fans etc which does happen so I
do it late at night to test and then
we'll look for the patterns and I'll
have an assistant do this or I'll do it
myself can usually be done really
quickly the average must be 7 or higher
alright the average for how much would
you recommend this to a friend has to be
7 or higher so some of you who are
familiar with a Net Promoter Score this
is a very simplistic way of approaching
that on social media to try to get
something that is resembling statistical
significance art so I do those two
things and end up rejecting about 90% of
the inbound sponsor inquiries so that's
about it if you're interested in other
policies that I use or interested in
looking at what sponsorship of a podcast
like mine looks like you can go to Tim
dot blog forward slash sponsor and check
it out if you are not interested in
sponsoring the podcast please do not
submit the form there's nothing fancy or
exciting or anything that comes after it
you're not going to receive anything so
don't spam the out of us thanks
frequency I mentioned briefly before six
episodes per month the more you publish
the more it appears that you are favored
by the iTunes algorithm so if you are
trying to pop
in the rankings it makes a lot of sense
to put out say a preview episode of a
few minutes and this is very standard
practice for people who look into this
put up a preview episode hey here's
what's coming with season 1 whatever
might be and use that to then build up
the subscriber base and in the first
week that you publish your podcast put
out at least three episodes in rapid
succession say Monday Tuesday Wednesday
and drive as much traffic as possible to
subscribe that is one tip if the pissing
contest of iTunes ranks matters to you
and who are we kidding
we all have healthy egos if you're doing
this kind of thing so why not have fun
with it okay so next up we have some
blog questions and I'm gonna try to try
to jump through this pretty quickly
is it better to name a blog after
yourself for recognition or or to use a
company name to reach a broader audience
this is from Mari this depends a lot on
what outcome you're optimizing for my
blog has my name and face all over it
this is good if you have no desire and
no intention and 100% certainty that you
are not going to sell the blog as part
of a media company later alright but if
you use a brand name or a company name
like wire cutter for instance which was
created by my friend Brian lamb and
later sold for a very healthy chunk of
change
having Brian's name if it was the the
Brian lamb show is problematic because
he may have a lot of trouble selling
that company as a sort of key man and
it's very difficult to say have that
company be acquired and continue with
that name in bright lights on the
marquee if Brian himself does not
continue on at the company and he might
say as part of the acquisition agreement
need to vest over time to receive some
of the payout very very common but in
any case it makes it a little tougher
there is
book called built to sell that I would
encourage you check out by John Warlow
and there are others but if your goal is
even 10% potentially to sell then making
it your personal name is problematic but
that's a decision I made I don't regret
it
excuse me let's see there's some
questions about platform all right and
you know it seems that WordPress is kind
of the go-to any suggestions on platform
I am biased towards WordPress there are
many options I am biased towards
WordPress for the same reason that I'm
biased towards email let me explain what
that means I'm biased towards WordPress
because it is open source so if say
automatic automatic ma TTI C which is a
company I now advise they run WordPress
comm and the paid services associated
with hosted WordPress blogs they kind of
handle it all for you if for whatever
reason they disappeared went out of
business got bought by company didn't
like whatever WordPress as a platform
continues to exist and you can port your
site from place to place to place and
find people to help you with support
very easily or development this is not
true for closed box systems right so
WordPress is does not have any single
point of failure in other words so if I
spend years building up this blog I
don't have to worry about suddenly it
being non viable if a company goes
bankrupt or something like that that is
one of the appeals of WordPress another
appeal highly highly appealing element
is that out of the box it has some of
the best SEO possible or at least it
does not do anything in my experience
terribly offensive to Google so it tends
to get my content at least and over time
this improves as your page rank
increases and so on tends to get indexed
very very effectively for search engines
that is another benefit that I found of
WordPress there are other options now I
mentioned I favor email so why email
email compared to social media that is
what I mean because as many people have
experienced with this isn't shaking a
stick at these folks this is
this is perfectly predictable based on
their incentives to sell advertising
that Facebook or other companies that
have say fan pages publisher pages and
so on this is true for instagrams well
and every other platform if they want at
any point to change their algorithm or
reduce organic reach they can do so so I
asked I remember at one point someone I
met who had a very successful business
based on Facebook what it was like and
he said it's like owning the most
profitable McDonald's in the world on
top of an active volcano you just don't
know when it's going to change when it's
going to erupt when your business is
gonna vaporize and a lot of people have
seen that and I still use Facebook I
think it's it's tremendously useful it
has ten times the click-through rate of
many of the other social platforms that
I've experimented with so it still has a
very very high utility for me however as
someone who focused on risk mitigation
and controlling as many variables as
possible
I like email in the last few years have
have doubled and tripled and quadrupled
down on that focus why because that
direct means of communication cannot
easily be taken away from me and I can
switch email service providers there's a
flexibility and a persistence with that
that you just don't have as a guarantee
on social media platforms despite that
of course I am investing resources and
time in certain platforms such as
Instagram all right pointers on just
doing the damn thing and not getting
worked up about it being perfect when
getting started and this is this is
something a lot of people have trouble
with I would write posts if we're
talking about blog specifically that you
can target to one or two of your friends
don't try to be an empathic super genius
if that poses some type of challenge for
you don't try to write anything for the
world if you try to write something that
everyone will like no one will love it
so feel free to polarize and write for
one or two of your friends when I write
articles I want 10% of my audience to
love each post that's it
10% and my audience is about 70 percent
male 30% female me
6535 but predominantly male and I'm
looking for 10% my audience to love it
period what that means is over time say
each six months or something like that
everyone in my audience will see a post
for me that they say holy
this is the best thing I've read in ages
let me share this with 20 of my friends
all right I don't care about everyone
loving each piece and that removes a
tremendous amount of pressure for you to
figure everything out and play the kind
of Switzerland of editorial and please
everyone do not try to please everyone
try to create raving fans that comprise
maybe five to ten percent of your
audience for each post that's my goal I
don't care about the rest they'll
they'll have their turn later but for
now if they're like what I'll post on
microbiome and don't know how that's
boring a well that's fine you can
be born to you but 10% of my audience is
gonna love this and go completely
bonkers over the details so that's fine
you'll get your turn that's how I think
about it what are things that are easily
outsourced it should be outsourced to
save time
logos interest podcasts uploader
scheduler etc I despite my proclivity
for outsourcing and delegating do not
delegate writing so if there is a blog
post that is certainly longer in
editorial with my name on it than I've
written it I just don't epically feel
okay with not doing that many people
have no compunction about that and
that's fine that's their decision but a
lot of folks you know as famous bloggers
do not have not written on their blogs
personally in years I know this perfect
anything with my name is is written by
me with the exception of some very basic
say intro text for podcasts which is
really more procedural that stuff I
might have an editorial assistant help
with and logos certainly I'm not
designing myself I'm hiring someone
whether one-on-one or through 99designs
which I do use quite consistently and
intros of podcasts for sure the music
and so on I will hire someone else to
handle and that can range from
royalty-free music on many different
sites which you can find out there to
hiring so
to compose which was the case for the
new tribe of mentors podcast and some
people may notice on the tribe of
mentors podcast which i pushed out which
had shorter content much more frequently
right stayed at number one on cross all
of itunes for about a week straight
during book launch very useful
that's another story that the music was
the same music I had had originally
composed for the 4-hour chef video
trailer so if you want to see the movie
trailer of the 4-hour chef you can take
a look at that on the youtubes alright
next question if you run ads on your
blog uploader schedule there are things
you can use for social for instance
whether it's Edgar or others that can be
very very helpful for that particularly
if you're gonna take a vacation or
travel for WordPress the scheduling and
so on can be done within the UI within
the dashboard of WordPress so for any
editorial that we're scheduling out in
that way we simply use that for the
podcasts because the quality assurance
is so important to me on that I have
several sets of eyes and ears who double
check and confirm everything before it
goes out all right next
if you run ads on your blog I don't run
ads on my blog but I'll try to answer
the questionnaire roughly how much
revenue does one thousand visits on the
blog per month equate to five thousand
ten thousand twenty thousand this
depends on CPM all right cost per
thousand that I mentioned earlier and
that varies very widely depending on the
nature of the advertising and the nature
of your blog your editorial who are your
customers right so if you're selling if
you're selling infomercial products then
the price is probably gonna be much much
lower cost per thousand if you're
selling or if you're able to help say
Mercedes sell their highest and units or
Omega or Rolex sell watches you're gonna
be able to charge a very high premium
CPM so it depends partially on the
nature of your audience but CPM can
range from $2 CPM all the way up to 100
as I mentioned but the pricing changes
constantly and you have to look at say
display contextual is separate equal
lookup contextual advertising to learn
what that is and then there's something
called native advertising which leaves
them
really bad taste in my mouth which is
basically hidden advertising disguised
as editorial I I just don't like that at
all it just and there may be varieties
of that that I would find perfectly find
and not offensive but in generally I
find that to be code for tricking
audience into thinking something as
editorial when in fact it is an
advertorial but not explicitly disclosed
as such or disclosed in such a way that
it's really ambiguous so I do not do
that do you find that users stay on
blocks for longer when there are no ads
I don't think so I don't think it
matters
unless the ads are say of a pop up
variety or really interruptive to the
read is it more strategic to focus on
embedded affiliate income than ads
depends on your strategy so it depends
what you're optimizing for an embedded
affiliate income I would just be very
careful with you you need to make
certain disclosures if you're going to
do that to be on the right side of the
law
for instance particularly if you want to
secure any type of insurance policies to
protect you against libel claims and so
on which I would encourage if you're
going to take this seriously and build
it out and that is the reason if you go
to Tim dot blog you can search
disclosures and I think it might be
write up in one of the top nav bars it
almost certainly is and you'll see all
these FTC related disclosures that I
make which are really just insurance
policies otherwise it's like if you if
someone takes you out to lunch and tells
you about their product and then you
cover the product on the blog you could
run into a conflict that could actually
put you into some legal gray area at
best so you want to be very very very
conservative with that kind of stuff so
is it strategic depends on your strategy
I would recommend reading a book called
the blue ocean strategy to make some
decision than that really comes down to
creating your own category that you can
dominate and own versus trying to
compete in a pre-existing bloody
category the affiliate income one other
note on that if you are going to also
use email you have to be very very
careful about not using affiliate links
in email and you can look into the
regulations related to that
at what point is it necessary to seek
out guest editors can to contribute to
your blog never you don't have to ever
do that look at Tim Urban and wait but
why there are many many blogs many
different content creators on different
platforms who from start to finish will
only produce things themselves only
write things themselves that can be
extraordinarily successful and
profitable so you don't have to do that
I occasionally bring in guest
contributors on my blog because I enjoy
reading long-form content and by the way
if if anyone's wondering well should I
write things that are less than 500
words less than a thousand words some of
my blog posts are 10 to 20,000 words and
many of them are my most popular posts
that end up being perennial ii revisited
and much like real estate this is one of
my goals i want a blog post i put up to
be more valuable two years from now than
the day that i publish it and that
relates to Google juice and other things
but my most popular posts are all years
old at this point and they appreciate
over time so I go super long-form Tim
urban takes it to a whole new level and
I did a podcast episode with him if you
just search Tim Ferriss show Tim urban
listened to that oh my god I mean some
of his posts if you want to call him
posts are like seventy thousand words
that's a book it's bigger than some
books broken up into into sections
alright so you don't ever need to get
guest editors let's see next question
what are if any must-have widget
recommendations really nothing for the
blog that I can think of other than
based on everything I just said about
email I would encourage you to have
something for email capture it does not
need to be a pop-up or anything like
that but optimized for email capture
even if like me you don't email anything
for the next like two to three years and
of course you need to follow the rules
and regulations related to reactivating
such email but think about email very
very closely that would be my
recommendation and really that's about
it we had the same question about back
logging content the editorial
particularly if I have guest posts I can
actually spec out for the next three to
six
months and in many cases and then
comments this is a not a question from
Nadia but a question that I'll add what
to do with comments I have comments and
if you go to teamed-up blog and scan
down to the end of any blog post with
comments you will see that I have
comment rules if people violate those
comment rules that's like they're coming
in to my house for dinner kicking off
their shoes putting their filthy feet up
on my table and like spitting on the
ground I boot them I have no problem
blacklisting people you're gone it's a
one strike you're out policy period and
if people seem to be getting escalated
I'll say play nice now sometimes jump in
to say hey guys play nice and usually
that's enough to to correct behavior but
I'm cultivating a neighborhood you were
the mayor of a town so if you want to
let people break windows and on
each other's porches hey that's up to
you I don't allow that at all I
have a zero zero tolerance policy for
all that stuff look up the I think it's
the broken windows theory of crime and
you can understand why other people like
Seth Godin massively massively
successful blog zero comments so you
don't have to have comments I just like
the feedback and Mike my commenters raw
will often catch little mistakes that I
didn't that I've made or they will chime
in and I'll have a post on swimming
let's say and I'll be like hey I'm the
national team coach working with
Olympians just had two things to add
holy that's rad so I love
that kind of interaction and it is my
personality it's my fit but really all
these things should be an outgrowth of
your strengths and your interests in my
opinion if you want it to be sustainable
you're gonna need endurance to do this
over time and have endurance
you're gonna need enthusiasm you're
gonna need to be excited about what
you're doing and if you get into
podcasting blogs whatever it is just to
make money you're gonna be competing
against people who have the enthusiasm
and they're gonna bury you they're just
gonna out maneuver you and outlast you
at the very least so find something
you're stoked about life's too short to
otherwise alright guys that's it for now
I hope you have found this useful and
that's about all I have to add to this
please let me know if you enjoyed this
episode if you'd like more tactical
stuff on content creation like this be
up
other questions about these types of
themes these types of topics please let
me know probably the easiest place is on
Twitter at t Faris TF er R is s on
Twitter you can also hit me on Instagram
or Facebook Tim Ferriss on both of those
so t IM f e double are i double s and I
would imagine there'll be some show
notes on this so if you want to find
links to things I've mentioned just go
to teamed up log forward slash podcast
and find this episode along with every
other episode and as always thank you so
much for listening I love doing this
show and it's because of you guys so
thanks I'll talk to you soon hey guys
this is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday and that provides a little morsel
of fun for the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek comm all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books man oh man do a lot of listeners
of this podcast and readers of mine love
fresh books to the extent that I ended
up meeting with the CEO not very long
ago why are they so popular well they
are the number one cloud accounting
software designed exclusively for
self-employed professionals that's many
of you and used by more than 10 million
people you can send invoices track your
time and get paid very very quickly
which suits the needs of a lot of
freelancers a lot of thought
and beyond you can take pictures of
receipts you can link your credit card
and debit card so all the things you buy
automatically appear in your fresh books
in the right category so on and so forth
makes taxes easy makes invoices easy
makes your life easier and also in fact
I recommend a PDF they didn't ask me to
read this part by the way they put the
other PDF a while back called breaking
the time barrier subtitle how to unlock
your true earning potential so you can
search for breaking the time barrier a
lot of people ask me how can I get a
4-hour workweek with a service business
and the story in that ebook it's PDF is
the short answer it's really really good
so I think you should also check that
out so breaking the time error check it
out but also why not test out fresh
books claim your 30-day unrestricted
free trial at fresh ebooks.com forward
slash tim and enter tim ferriss two
hours and two S's in the how did you
hear about us section that sounds like
we're gonna get very little tracking
that's a lot of work but just go to
fresh books comm forward slash tim and
try it out because it is a very good
product and i think you will find it
simplifies your life enjoy this episode
is brought to you by for sigma deck you
might remember for sig Matic for their
mushroom coffee which was created by
those clever Finnish founders and when I
first mentioned that coffee on this
podcast the products sold out in less
than a week it lights you up like a
Christmas tree which can be really
useful however recently I've been
testing the opposite side of the
spectrum a new product and that is their
reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my
day to get to sleep as you guys may know
longtime listeners at least I struggled
with insomnia for decades I have a
largely fixed that but still shutting
off my monkey brain has never been easy
it still isn't easy very often and I
found reishi which have been fascinated
by for a few years now has been very
very effective and calming their old
formula however for sig Maddox old
formula included stevia and I like to
avoid sweeteners all sweeteners for a
host of reasons and I then just ping
them and asked hey guys
I would love to experiment with this and
maybe actually suggest it but I
like a version without sweeteners if
you'd be open to it too much of headache
don't worry and they are always game for
experimentation so they created a
special custom version without the
stevia without sweeteners now it is part
of my nightly routine their ratio elixir
comes in single serving packets which
are perfect for travel and in fact I'm
about to leave the country right now and
I have a packet in front of me that's
just gonna sit in the end of my carry-on
bag
you only need hot water and it mixes
very very easily here are some
recommended copy that they put in the
read so I'm gonna read it and I'll give
you my take quote a warning for those in
the experimental mindset reishi is
strong and bitter in parentheses like
any great medicine so if the bitterness
is too much I recommend trying it with
honey and or nut milk such as almond
milk end quote
so I'm gonna say no you should suck it
up and you should drink the tea because
it's not that bitter and maybe should
take the advice of all Chinese people
when they're criticizing youngins when
they say boo and I'm sure they're cool
which means you're not able to eat
bitterness bitter is in many cases an
indication of things that help liver
detoxification and so on not saying
that's the case here but I've tested
this ratio later on family members on
friends everybody has liked it it's a
little bit earthy it's not that hard so
I would just say suck it up and know
don't put it in honey or a nut milk or
any of that just drink the goddamn
tea it's delicious I think all right if
you like puer that kind of stuff that
type of tea you're gonna dig it so just
try it okay back to then my read if
you'd like to naturally improve your
sleep both on set and quality I think
naturally you might just enjoy this
ratio lecture without any sweeteners it
has organic reishi extract organic
fueled mint extract organic rosehips
extract organic Tulsi extract and that's
it no fancy stuff no artificial
whatchamacallit anything so check it out
go to four sigma deck comport size
Ferriss and get 20% off this special
batch I don't know if they're gonna be
making much more of this
since it was made specifically for you
guys so do me a favor and try it out so
that they continue to be open to
experimenting with me to create products
for you guys specifically check it out
for sig Matic that's fo you are SI g ma
TI c calm forward slash ferrous fe RR
ISS and get 20% off the special batch
and you must use the code at Ferris to
receive a discount fer our ISS so again
go to for Sigma tech comm forward slash
Ferris and then use code Ferris for 20%
off of this rare exclusive limited run
of reishi mushroom elixir for nighttime
routines without any sweeteners enjoy
you